[Music]
what Wyatt
it what that's it pop quiz I was in the
high school worship band at my church oh
my god me too I played guitar I played
keys I was an honor roll student my mom
had a license plate holder I can't
remember many memories of me being young
when I was at that church so I might
lose I also have no short-term memory so
what is the source of humanity's
original sin when Eve ate the apple
because apparently women just ruin
everything yeah yeah I believe because
they took that this name snakes
Apple they ate the Apple from the tree
the first female character in the
biblical canon leading man towards the
original sin with her wanton sexiness Oh
Cain killed Abel right he was a bad one
wait oh good lord I'm going with Cain
killed Abel for 100 mm hmm yeah I want
to say that it was Cain came after Abel
yes that's right Cain did kill Abel Abel
killed yeah what did God asked Abraham
to do for him
and this is where my biblical knowledge
has reached its end I don't remember at
all to kill his son kill his son killing
is the healing here a lot of Sun a lot
of killing he asked him to kill his kid
yeah and then he's like just kidding you
don't have to
can use a go he's like your crazy mother
I respect it I respect that
even free of the plagues that fell upon
Egypt I know we've got our locusts the
blood riding the river the stuff on
their bodies spoils the boils and was
boils that's three already
what was that like cartoon film it was
like early 2000s it was like about all
of that I learned out in the pretty jet
what is the first book in the New
Testament
oh oh oh yeah duh of course it's Genesis
you said the New Testament right New
Testament oh no John you Matthew is it
John Matthew John Matthew Mark Luke John
I'm gonna go with John you could go with
Matthew oh no let's do this
not in
boom cuz I knew that too Matthew okay
okay yeah I knew it was Matthew Mark
Luke John Jasmine but be cool if there's
an apostle named Jasmine that would be
Dell yeah that'd be great
what are the ten minutes all right all
of them number one chill out I know
number five is the bow shot killed
[Music]
disrespect your father and mother do you
know I do not
yeah anybody not like thou shalt not
tell false something oh yeah oh don't
worship false guys yeah
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
oh you get the wording down on that and
everything
you're not solution email will on other
people that's one right but he's shaking
your head remember I don't give up never
give up never surrender never that's
probably one of it thou shalt not give
up that's how I shall never give up
should we maybe we'll just be done with
this okay
okay we can't say his name in vain oh
come on
that's a given it's so easy there is
stuff that doesn't really age quite as
well but the initial just morality of it
is like okay those are just good life
lessons those are good things to live by
yes
c- f